l'île des soeurs secteur verdoyant de
quatre kilomètres carrés à l'entrée de
montréal 21 mille personnes y habitent
dont plus de 3000 ici sur la pointe nord
dans un tout nouveau quartier juste à
côté du pont samuel de champlain
en quelques années seulement la vue a
changé radicalement quand on arrive de
la rive-sud et les tours poussent encore
c'est là que j'avais donné rendez-vous
le maire d'arrondissement
jean françois parenteau j'ai connu les
le dessert à l'époque avait 5000
personnes pendant longtemps je vois pas
une île des soeurs à 30 35 mille
personnes se seraient selon - invivable
sécu lille est relié à montréal
seulement par l'autoroute
elle manque d'infrastructures mais aussi
de certains services
on a dû par exemple ouvrir des classes
de primaire dans cet édifice à bureaux
par manque d espace dans les deux écoles
existantes mais avec la vigueur du
marché immobilier et surtout grâce à
l'arrivée du rem l'an prochain les
résidents savent que leur il sera plus
attrayant que jamais s'il est le seul un
pillage point lolo on est un peu mal
pris et lorraine c'est sûr que c'est un
plus pour les gens qui vont vouloir se
rendre et aux parts au centre-ville des
tours qui vont
si on me faire beaucoup de congestion
est bloqué sur le centre ville
bonsoir et je vous souhaite la livre
montréal propose un plan particulier
d'urbanisme 1pp eu question d'encadrer
les promoteurs et de prévoir
l'aménagement de tout le secteur du nord
de l'île si ce qui est mentionné dans le
document du ppe
c'est que ces édifices love vont
disparaître derrière il va y avoir un
secteur résidentiel est ce qu'il propose
c'est que les édifices soient tous ici
collé sur le bord de la rue
l'association des résidants demeure
inquiète l'île-des-soeurs selon elle ne
doit pas devenir un deuxième greffe en
temps on veut un développement
harmonieux avec le quartier avec la
nature qui existe dans le quartier on
veut des études qui nous prouve que les
infractions sont capables de recevoir 25
ou 30 mille personnes on veut aussi une
planification des achats de terrains
pour les équipements collectifs de
proximité
jean françois parent on tour se fait
rassurant ce qui est proposé avec le
plan métropolitain d'aménagement parle
de santis personnes à l'hectare sont
incomparables comprendre réfutant ces
150 personnes à l'hectare
il promet que les nouveaux quartiers
auront 30 % des espaces verts que les
stationnements seront surtout souterrain
et que les futures tours autour du rem
ne dépasseront pas celle déjà
construites
actuellement la plus haute compte 36
étages ont 25 ans dessus étaient 70 72 m
mais pas homogène on veut une gradation
alors on veut pas d'être collé de la
même hauteur on veut une variation on
veut que ça soit respectueux et on veut
sur toute la lumière percole à
l'intérieur mais c'est de l'autre côté
de l'île au sud que s'apprête à être
construit le plus haut gratte ciel de
l'île des soeurs
une tour de 42 étages la troisième phase
du projet symphonia qui offrira à terme
900 unités résidentielles
tout est conforme aux règles le journal
j'ai respecté mais plusieurs se
demandent quel impact
or à ce projet sur la circulation dans
l'île quoi qu'il en soit tous ces
nouveaux développements ont la cote chez
les acheteurs tout comme le marché des
immeubles déjà existants diane l'horaire
est agente immobilière
l'engouement pour les fidèles se fait
particulièrement sentir depuis l'an
dernier les propriétés se vendent
rapidement les gens veulent être le
dessin oui définitivement
maintenant ça va vraiment très bien on
se trouve souvent dans des situations
d'offres multiples c'est pas rare de
voir deux trois quatre cinq offres sur
un produit et se lance dans une semaine
seulement sur le marché on vivait pas ça
souvent
donc maintenant on vit ça presque
constamment sa clientèle recherchent la
tranquillité de lille et la proximité du
centre-ville des atouts énormes pour des
gens plus aisés
l'arrivée prochaine du rem ne fait
qu'accroître leur intérêt ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
n'ont rien